now I've spent my career in the trenches
where crimes occur where innocents are
victimized even slaughtered I have
actually fought on that battlefield for
more than three decades where justice is
sought for victims and I have long
fought for a level playing field
particularly for women the often silent
and forgotten victims of crime
I have even advocating changing the name
of the criminal justice system to the
victims justice system the victim who
never chose to be a part of the criminal
justice system in the first place I
started the first domestic violence unit
in a prosecutor's office in the nation
in the late 1970s as District Attorney I
created a sex crimes Bureau my crusade
for women and children existed long
before the hashtag me to movement
I respect facts I know the law and I
understand what's at stake our criminal
justice system is the most revered in
the world the constitutional rights of
all Americans are etched in stone and it
is in this context that I analyze the
situation we're in now
number one due process requires equal
protection under the law for the victim
as well as the accused number two in all
criminal prosecutions the accused shall
enjoy the right to a speedy trial number
three no warrants shall issue or
criminal charge filed without probable
cause number four the accused has the
right to a trial by an impartial jury
the right to remain silent the right to
not only confront his accuser but to
cross-examine as well number five the
burden of proof in every criminal case
is beyond a reasonable doubt and that
burden of proof is on the prosecutor
number six
as for the accused there is AB
lutely no burden to speak or even
present a case now over the years we've
learned certain facts number one sex
crimes are underreported because of the
victims fears of not being believed or
her fear of the perpetrator
number two the recidivism rate of sex
offenders is estimated to be as high as
70% so let us apply these foundational
truths to the Christine Ford and Brett
Kavanaugh situation what motivation
might someone have to come forward 36
years after an event and how credible
could such an accusation be some members
of Congress don't care about any of this
the woman has to be believed that he is
guilty forget a trial due process or
even hearing from the victim that
Constitution be damned
I believe dr. Blasi Ford because she's
telling the truth not only do women like
dr. Ford who bravely comes forward need
to be heard but they need to be believed
they need to be believed I believe dr.
Ford I believe the survivor here there's
every reason to believe her
I believe professor Ford I think she's
credible and I think when the
investigation is finished and when she
testifies and Judge Cavanaugh testifies
I think a majority of senators will find
her credible the dismissal of the
fundamental rules of our justice system
by congressmen senators Congress women
is stunning and anyone who's prosecuted
sex crimes cases knows that criminals
rarely commit crimes in public or while
a video tape is running so in addition
to the he-said she-said we look for
corroborating evidence after we hear the
core accusation of who when where and
how now we don't expect minuscule
details when a victim is being
traumatized but here the alleged victim
does not know the address a date the
owner of the house how she got home that
night why what was her appearance when
she got home she was 15 did her mother
see her did she suffer a behavioral
change dinner grades go down to whom did
she complain and when in sex crimes
cases in particular recent outcry is
compelling and reliable when the memory
is fresh is when you would most expect
the complaint when is the first time she
even used the name Cavanaugh here there
is no indication of any of that physical
evidence such as torn clothes injuries
visits to a doctor a hospital
photographs there is none corroborating
witnesses not only are there none what
one had just reported that she heard
about this at school which
tracted herstory saying but I didn't
think I'd actually have to defend that a
man's reputation family career and civil
liberties are at stake and you make a
claim and you didn't think you had to be
honest and finally does the complaint
ring true and a complaint does not gain
credibility based on the name of the
accused if that were the case Bill
Clinton's accusers would certainly have
gotten their day in court and one of the
credibility and background of the
accused 65 women who've gone to school
with him dated and work for him and know
him have come forward to say that his
whole life has been about respecting
women why if there was such a high
recidivism rate a repeat of these crimes
in violent sex crimes cases have we
never heard anything like this after six
FBI investigations and motivation
whenever a complaint is old any
prosecutor would ask why now dr. Ford
said she was outed well it was she who
contacted two Democrat Congress women
six weeks before she came forward and 36
years after it allegedly happened and
why take a lie-detector test if she
believed what she was saying why would
she need an outsider to affirm whether
what she's saying is true might it be
part of a long hatched plan to reveal
investigators ask for lie-detector tests
and by the way they are so unreliable
that I fought for a law in New York that
wouldn't allow police to require women
to take why detector test because they
are unreliable
now while Ford is highly political one
incidence is even more compelling do you
remember when the president nominated
Brett Kavanaugh we heard that
Cavanaugh's mother was a
judge Ford's parents follow me
Ford's parents had a foreclosure claim
against them and their home in 1970 in
1996 in Maryland
Ford's parents lost their home the judge
ruled against them the judge was a woman
the judge was Brett Cavanaugh's mother
many times victims are teed up by
attorneys who want to become famous or
rich sometimes they're even used by
politicians take a look she's not
prepared to talk with them at a hearing
on Monday this just came out 48 hours
ago no not 48 hours ago 36 years ago
delay becomes even more absurd when she
needs to drive across the country to
Washington because she won't or can't
fly she was an intern in Hawaii a few
years ago how did she make that trip did
she drive or surf across the ocean from
California to Hawaii and what's with
this we need the FBI there's no federal
crime here they keep saying we need the
FBI but they don't ask for it because
they know it can't happen if you want an
investigation call the local police or
911 truth and justice and law and order
don't change depending on the political
parties women are to be believed not
because a political party thinks they
should be but when they sound credible
and present a believable scenario and
believability does not depend on the
party of the complainants and all men
who were accused have a right to be
cloaked in the presumption of innocence
unless and until proof beyond a
reasonable doubt shatters that
presumption and it matters not what your
politics are that Lady Justice is blind
has been the truth in our sin
from time immemorial I have honored that
lady I've admired her and I've been in
awe of her for as long as I can remember
but now I fear for her I fear for Lady
Justice but not just Lady Justice our
institutions and our bedrock
constitutional rules that have made
America what Ronald Reagan referred to
as the shining city on the hill we can
never allow that to happen
and that's my open